.
Christine Hug wurde vor 42 Jahren
geboren und als Knabe erzogen.
Doch weder die wohlbehütete Kindheit,
die steile Karriere im Militär
noch die erfüllten Lebensträume
von Eigenheim und Familie
vermochten das Leben
ehrlich schön zu machen.
Christine
fühlte sich nie wohl als Mann.
Doch erst nach 37 Lebensjahren
fasst sie den Mut,
die Frau zu sein, die sie ist.
Es war die Angst, dass es gesell-
schaftlich nicht akzeptiert ist.
Ich selber habe mir eingeredet,
dass es abartig sei.
Dass es etwas Negatives sei.
Damit verbunden die Angst,
nicht mehr akzeptiert
und ausgeschlossen zu werden.
Im Prinzip Angst vor Zurückweisung.
Ich habe mir immer überlegt:
Kann ich mir mich als alten Mann
oder alte Frau vorstellen?
Und als alten Mann konnte
ich mir mich nicht vorstellen.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Ich singe
"Tierlitänzli, Chatzeschwänzli".
# Tierlitänzli, Chatzeschwänzli.
S Chätzli wott go muuse.
# S Müsli isch is Löchli gsprunge
und cha nümme use.
(Fernes Echo)
# Tierlitänzli, Chatzeschwänzli.
# Dasmol ischs nöd grate.
Aus dem Kind von damals
ist eine Frau geworden.
Heute, mit 42, möchte sie das
Frausein in vollen Zügen geniessen.
Christine steht erst in ihrem fünften
Lebensjahr als geoutete Transfrau.
Davor wurde sie
von aussen als Mann wahrgenommen
und hat sich wie ein Mann verhalten.
Wann ist Mann nun eine Frau?
Wie definiert sich
die Frau von heute?
Und welches Geschlecht
hat eigentlich unsere Seele?
Diese Fragen begleiten Christine
schon ihr Leben lang.
Heute hält sie als Expertin
Vorträge zu diesen Themen.
* Musik aus dem Computer *
Ich möchte Christine Hug
willkommen heissen,
die sich zur Verfügung gestellt hat,
mit uns diesen Auftrag zu machen.
Wir wissen, wie es ist,
als Frau zu leben,
aber nicht, wie als Mann. V.a.
kennen wir den Unterschied nicht.
Ich will gar nicht viel mehr sagen.
Christine, du kannst das besser.
Danke, dass du da bist,
ich übergebe dir das Wort.
Was macht es aus,
sich als Frau zu fühlen,
obwohl man nicht als Frau
geboren wurde?
Was ist es,
dass man sich als Frau fühlt?
Man sagt,
dass die Seele kein Geschlecht hat.
Oder beide Geschlechter.
Beides sei vorhanden.
Eigentlich sind in jedem Menschen
beide Seiten vorhanden.
Diese äussern sich unterschiedlich
und haben Auswirkungen
auf die Persönlichkeit.
Christine kommt im Mai 1980
als erstes von zwei Kindern
auf die Welt und bekommt
den Namen Christian Urs Hug.
Die Familie lebt das konventionelle,
gute Leben am Stadtrand von Zürich.
Die Mutter ist Hausfrau, der Vater
Polizei- und Militäroffizier.
Niemand ahnt,
dass im Kopf des jungen Blondschopfs
bereits damals grundlegende Fragen
der Geschlechtsidentität kreisen.
Der Gedanke, weshalb ich
nicht als Frau geboren wurde,
war schon sehr früh da.
Den hatte ich schon
während Primarschulzeiten.
Schon damals
hatte ich solche Gedanken.
Hätte ich damals mit
einem Zauberstab wünschen können,
ob ich Mann oder Frau sein will,
hätte ich Frau gesagt - ganz klar.
Aber ich wusste, dass das
nicht geht, dass es anders ist.
Also musste ich das andere leben.
Wie geht man damit um,
wenn man schon als Kind merkt,
dass man gern anders wäre,
als man ist?
Die Angst ist nie ein guter Berater,
und doch begleitet sie einen
in genau solchen Situationen.
Nur heimlich traute sich Christian,
ab und zu ein Kleid seiner Mutter
anzuziehen
und damit sein tiefes Bedürfnis
zu stillen.
Es war sehr wohltuend,
wie ein Ausbrechen.
Aber niemand durfte davon erfahren,
denn es war ja abartig, das zu tun.
Ich hatte
dann ein schlechtes Gewissen.
Es steigerte sich im Innern,
und ich dachte,
ich sei wohl
nicht ganz richtig im Kopf.
Dementsprechend
wollte ich mich anpassen.
Ich dachte:
Sobald ich dann Familie habe,
werden die blöden Gedanken
von alleine verschwinden.
(Mann) Nochmal.
Mäuschen?
Geprägt vom eigenen Vater
und dessen Leidenschaft fürs Militär,
schlägt Christine in jungen Jahren
den Weg zum Berufssoldaten ein
und legt eine steile Karriere hin.
Innert weniger Jahre
wird sie zum Oberstleutnant
und damit zum Kommandanten
eines 300-köpfigen Panzerbataillons.
Ich konzentrierte mich
auf die Karriere -
sowohl auf das Militär
als auch auf das Studium,
was zu dem Zeitpunkt parallel lief.
Ich empfand es nicht
per se als Kompensationshaltung,
um mich von den Gedanken
des Mann- oder Frauseins abzulenken.
Aber es kam mir sehr gelegen,
denn ich musste mich mit diesen
Fragen nicht auseinandersetzen.
Ich versuchte, meine Aufgaben
zu lösen und weiterzukommen.
Ich konnte mich
auf das Fachliche konzentrieren.
So konnte ich den Fragen mir
selber gegenüber aus dem Weg gehen.
An einem Fest des Militärmuseums
hilft
der damals 27-jährige Christian mit
und präsentiert verschiedene Panzer.
Unter den Besucherinnen
ist auch Tanja.
Sie steigt zu Christian
in den kalten Panzer
und mit ihr wird dieser
schlagartig zu einem Ort der Liebe.
Und plötzlich scheint
das ganz normale, sorgenfreie Leben
nur noch einen Atemzug entfernt.
Es war keine Liebe auf
den ersten Blick im plakativen Sinn.
Mit Tanja
lernte ich einen Menschen kennen,
mit dem ich auf persönlicher Ebene
unglaublich viel gemeinsam habe.
Die Art und Weise des Austauschs,
die Interessen, die Ansichten ...
Ein Mensch,
der einen als Person ergänzt.
Auch für die zehn Jahre ältere Tanja
ist nach diesem Nachmittag
im Panzer klar,
dass sie den Menschen ihres Lebens
gefunden hat.
Ich habe einfach gemerkt:
In diesem Mann steckt mehr,
als ich je von einem Mann spürte.
Sei es das Einfühlungsvermögen,
das Zuhören,
das Eingehen auf Fragen und das
tiefgründige Beantworten von Fragen.
Wir kamen
beinahe ins Philosophieren.
Es war unglaublich kurzweilig.
Wir unterschätzten beide total
die Zeit.
Es vergingen 3-4 Std.,
und wir dachten,
wir seien erst 30. Min im Panzer.
In diesem Moment wusste ich,
dass ich mit diesem Mann
eine Familie gründen wollte.
Eine Woche später
traf ich Christian,
wir hatten uns verabredet.
Als Erstes nahm er mich in die Arme
und sagte:
"Tanja, wo warst du die ganze Zeit?
Dich habe ich gesucht."
Die beiden
heiraten nur wenige Monate später
und gründen mit der Geburt
von Tochter Julia eine Familie.
Besser?
Besser so, wenn es so kratzt?
Ist besser so, oder?
Tipptopp.
Halt. Gut so.
Mit dem eigenen Haus auf dem Land und
drei Pferden hat sich die Familie Hug
ihren eigenen Lebenstraum erfüllt.
Nach aussen hin ein Bilderbuchleben.
Im Innern von Christian,
der damals noch als Mann lebt,
tut sich jedoch
ein seelischer Abgrund auf.
100 % auf der Scheibe.
Chrige,
ich gehe kurz einen Kaffee trinken.
Das ist gut.
- Ich bin hier in Kürze durch.
Die Weide ist gemacht.
Der war ganz gut.
Oha!
- Gut gemacht, Julia.
Für mich war klar: Ich hatte
die Partnerin fürs Leben gefunden.
Es war klar, dass wir heiraten
und eigene Kinder haben werden.
Dann dachte ich, dass sich diese
komischen Gedanken legen werden.
Doch dem war nicht so.
Dieses heile Familienleben
funktionierte
sieben Jahre nach Julias Geburt gut.
Alle ...
Viele "Lebensträume"
konnten verwirklicht werden.
Und trotzdem merkte ich,
dass etwas fehlte.
Es fehlt an nichts im Leben,
und doch fehlt irgendwie alles.
* Pferdeschnauben *
Das wahre Ich brennt, will raus.
Zu lange
wurde es unterdrückt und missbilligt.
Christine kann nicht mehr.
Die Kräfte, die an ihr reissen,
sind zu stark.
Sie muss eine Entscheidung treffen.
Ungeachtet dessen,
wen sie alles verlieren könnte.
Eine Ohnmacht macht sich breit.
Die Gedanken kreisen unaufhörlich:
Wer bin ich, wer will ich sein,
und was riskiere ich zu verlieren?
Der stets aufgestellte
und aktive Christian leidet zunehmend
an einer starken Lust-
und Antriebslosigkeit,
fühlt sich fehl am Platz, falsch.
Es war die Müdigkeit
all dieser vielen Jahre,
in denen man einen Teil des Selbst
unterdrückte und nicht wahrnahm.
Wenn ich damals
einfach weitergemacht,
es nicht beachtet hätte,
wäre ich wohl in
eine tiefe Depression geschlittert.
Auch Tanja fällt in dieser Zeit auf,
wie sich ihr Mann verändert.
Sie befürchtet, dass er eine Affäre
mit einer anderen Frau hat.
Christine weiss: Entweder
rückt sie mit der Wahrheit heraus
oder alles geht in die Brüche,
auch sie selber.
Damals versuchte ich, meine Gedanken
in einem Brief an sie festzuhalten.
Ich war nicht in der Lage,
darüber zu sprechen.
Es fiel mir viel zu schwer.
Die Angst vor
dieser völlig unbekannten Situation,
von der man nicht wusste,
ob sie eskalieren,
in welche Richtung sie sich
entwickeln würde, war extrem.
Ich hatte noch nie solche Angst.
* Melancholische Musik *
Christine spricht in dem Brief
an ihre Ehefrau zum ersten Mal aus,
was sie seit der Primarschule
beschäftigt:
"Ich bin eine Frau
in einem männlichen Körper."
"Ich bin kein Mann,
ich will kein Mann sein."
Sie hinterlegt den Brief
und geht arbeiten.
Als sie am Abend nach Hause kommt,
redet sie mit ihrer Frau
über ihr wahres Ich.
Christian war am Arbeiten
und schrieb,
dass wir am Abend
darüber reden müssten,
sobald Julia im Bett ist.
Ich fragte mich, was los sei.
Was kommt auf mich zu?
Dann stand Christian
als Christine vor der Tür.
Da zog es mir den Boden
unter den Füssen weg.
Ich wusste nicht,
ob es ein Scherz sein sollte.
Geschminkt,
mit Perücke und High Heels.
Sie sah wie eine Nutte aus,
war sehr billig gekleidet.
Ich dachte, ich sehe nicht richtig.
Und, ja ...
Da hatte ich natürlich einen Schock.
Ich wusste nicht,
ob ich weinen oder lachen sollte.
Ich setzte mich wortwörtlich
rückwärts auf die Treppe.
Ich kriegte wirklich die Krise.
Dieses Gefühl,
Christian verloren zu haben,
dieses Gefühl,
dass er abspringen wird,
hatte ich, als er
mit den Hormontabletten begann.
Weil ...
Plötzlich wurde mir bewusst,
dass Christian
nicht mehr wie Christian roch.
Christian fühlte sich nicht mehr
wie Christian an.
Es ...
Christian war psychisch
nicht mehr Christian.
An diesem Punkt dachte ich,
dass ich Christian verlieren würde.
An manchen Tagen war ich stocksauer.
Und ich war traurig und verwirrt -
orientierungslos
und völlig neben der Spur.
Das war damals der Grund,
weshalb ich sagte,
dass ich
meinen Mann verlieren würde.
Und ich hatte immer das Gefühl,
dass ich meinen Mann
bei einem Sterbeprozess begleitete.
Trotz aller Verlustängste gibt es
für Christine kein Zurück mehr.
Sie fängt sofort
mit der Hormontherapie an
und entscheidet sich früh für eine
geschlechtsangleichende Operation.
Christine weiss, dass alles,
was jetzt noch auf sie zukommen mag,
niemals so schmerzhaft sein wird,
wie die Unterdrückung ihrer selbst
während so vieler Jahre.
* Melancholische Klavierklänge *
Durch die Hormone durchläuft
man eine Art zweite Pubertät.
Aber es geht viel schneller,
ist zeitlich gestrafft.
Es ändert sich viel, körperlich
gibt es viele Umstellungen.
Und auch beim Empfinden,
bei den Gefühlen.
Es ist eindrücklich, den Unterschied
zwischen männlichen
und weiblichen Hormonen zu erleben.
(Mann)
Beginnen wir mit Christian.
Ich habe aufgeschrieben,
dass du sehr lieb bist.
Das freut mich.
Denn das ist nicht bei allen so.
Ja, du bist sehr hilfsbereit.
Du hilfst der Familie, den Eltern.
Du bereitest viel Freude.
Aber du kannst dich
auch mit Geduld hinsetzen
und etwas Schönes für den Bruder
basteln oder bauen.
Was machst du so für ihn?
Kannst du davon erzählen?
Da muss ich kurz überlegen.
Was kannst du Schönes machen?
Eine BRIO-Bahn.
Das kannst du alles schon?- Ich
habe einen Plan, um nachzuschauen.
Nach Plan kannst
du das zusammenstecken?- Ja.
Das ist prima.- Ich beginne
immer mit dem grossen Tor.
Du bist ein richtiger Sheriff,
dass du das kannst.- Ja.
Deshalb trägt du heute den Stern.
- Ja.
Kommst du mit den Gläsern?
Sobald ich 100 Hände habe,
sage ich es euch.
Gut.
- Danke, Julia.
Hier der Fleischteller.
- Danke.
Brot?
- Ja, danke.
Wie viele
waren an dieser Veranstaltung?
Ungefähr 20 Personen.
- Wirklich?
Und gab es interessante Fragen?
Ja, sie stellten viele Fragen.
Willst du noch Wasser?- Gerne.
Oder von dem mit Kohlensäure?
- Nein, lieber von dem.
Danke.
Hast du heute deinen Test erhalten?
- Nein.
Haben sie ihn vergessen?
- Ja.
Vermutlich
hat es Frau Steiner vergessen,
dies Herrn Flückiger zu sagen.
Die Englischhausaufgaben hat Kimo
Neva mitgeben.
Die habe ich erhalten.
- Und gemacht?
Nein.
* Unterdrücktes Lachen *
Wann gedenkst du, sie zu machen?
- Morgen.
Morgen hast du kein Englisch?
Wir haben am Dienstag Englisch.
- Morgen ist Mittwoch.
Und dann am Dienstag
eine Woche später.
Super, haben wir den Tag geschafft.
Ich bereue nicht,
dass ich es erst so spät machte.
Der wesentliche Schritt ...
Hätte ich es früher getan,
wäre es wohl
nie zu dieser Beziehung gekommen.
Und ich hätte
meine Tochter Julia nicht.
Ich bereue es gar nicht,
dass ich es erst so spät tat.
Sonst hätte ich das
vermutlich nicht.
Und ...
Unglaublich viel,
was mir im Leben wichtig ist,
hätte ich sonst nicht gehabt.
* Rascheln *
So.
- Hallo.
Geht es jetzt besser?
- Ja.
Hast du eine Idee für einen Scherz?
Habe ich schon gesagt.
- Nein.
Sie hatten die grandiose Idee,
einen nassen Schwamm
auf die Türe zu legen.
Sodass dieser runterfällt,
wenn man die Türe öffnet.
Er fiel auch runter,
aber Herr Flückiger war bereits weg.
Einfach nicht
mit einem Kessel machen.
* Julia lacht. *
Kopfkino ausschalten.
Als Julia von der Transition
ihres Papas erfährt,
ist sie acht Jahre alt.
Geändert habe sich seither nichts,
wie sie sagt.
Ausser, dass Papa jetzt Nana heisse.
Sie sagte mir, dass sie sich
als Mann nicht so wohlfühle,
dass sie eine Frau sein möchte
und dass es dafür
Möglichkeiten gebe.
So hat sie es in die Wege geleitet.
Es hat sich nichts gross verändert.
Nein.
Gute Nacht.
- Gute Nacht, Julia.
Schlaf gut.
Die Gesichter sieht man nicht.
- Nein.
Also, gute Nacht.
- Danke, dir auch.
Neben der Familie war die Armee
schon immer ein wichtiger Ankerpunkt
in Christines Leben.
Auch hier muss sie sich
als Transfrau outen
und damit rechnen,
ihren Job zu verlieren,
denn die Schweizer Armee steht eher
für konservativ-patriarchalisches
als für modernes Gedankengut.
Ich stehe wie vor einer Kreuzung
bzw. vor der Strasse des Lebens.
Eine grosse, gut ausgebaute,
breite Schnellstrasse
mit einer sanften Kurve nach links.
In dieser Linkskurve befindet sich
rechts ein kleiner Trampelpfad.
Dieser verschwindet im Gebüsch,
führt ins Ungewisse.
Bei dieser sinnbildlichen Kreuzung
sagt dir der Verstand,
links zu gehen.
Dort ist das bequeme, gute Leben.
Aber das Gefühl sagt dir,
dass du rechts gehen musst.
* Dynamische Streicherklänge *
Als ich ins Militär ging,
war es sicher ein Vorteil,
ein Mann zu sein.
Denn als ich mit dem Militär begann,
hätte ich als Frau
nicht zu meiner Wunschtruppengattung
Panzer gehen können.
Das ging erst einige Jahre später.
Bei der Rekrutierung hiess es,
dass für die Kampftruppen -
dazu gehören Panzer -
nur Männer zugelassen seien,
und keine Frauen.
Heute dürfen Frauen
in den Kampftruppen dienen,
jedoch gilt Transidentität
im Schweizer Armeereglement
theoretisch immer noch
als Untauglichkeitsgrund.
Trans war ein Untauglichkeitsgrund.
Von meinem beruflichen Bereich
weiss ich,
dass es bis dahin
keine Fälle mit Betroffenen gab.
Im schlimmsten Fall ...
Wenn sie zum Schluss gekommen wären,
der Beruf sei nicht mehr ausführbar,
hätte ich etwas anderes
suchen müssen.
Das war für mich der Punkt,
an dem ich sagen musste:
Das bin ich,
ich musste mich so lange verleugnen.
Wenn das nun die Konsequenzen
dafür sind, dann ist es so.
Nicht, dass ich das wollte,
aber ich konnte mich in dieser
Hinsicht nicht länger verleugnen.
Ich war bereit,
die Konsequenzen zu tragen.
Zwei Dinge: Das eine besprechen
später Kader und Stellvertreter.
Zu den Statusmeldungen,
die vorher ein Thema waren.
Der Status wird dann gemeldet,
wenn es
ein ernsthaftes Problem gibt,
das dazu führt, dass der Auftrag
nicht weitergeführt werden kann.
Oder wenn es sonst nichts
zu tun gibt.
Und nur dann.
Im Gefecht
interessiert der Status niemanden.
Ausser bei einem reellen Problem,
bei dem ihr Hilfe braucht.
Gut. Die Kader können übernehmen.
So sind wir wieder
bei den klassischen Rollenbildern.
Wieso soll es seltsam sein,
wenn eine Frau eine Anweisung gibt?
Ist es berechtigt, so zu denken?
Ich sage:
Nein, ist es nicht. Sondern:
Was für eine Person ist das,
und welche Kompetenzen hat sie?
* Unverständliche Gespräche *
Bist du doch dabei?
-  Halleluja.
* Er spricht leise. *
Die Akzeptanz hat mich
darin bestärkt, mich selber zu sein.
Das war für mich sehr positiv.
Es ist, es ist ...
Ich wurde akzeptiert.
Für mich ging es
beinahe angenehmer weiter.
Denn ich hatte diese Last
mir selber gegenüber nicht mehr.
Ich konnte freier, offener sein.
Dadurch hatte ich das Gefühl,
dass ich bei vielen Dingen
noch besser akzeptiert wurde
als vorher.
(Mann) ... die Flanke zu schützen.
Ich wiederhole.
Es ist Führung per se -
man will es ruhig vermitteln,
die Situationsübersicht behalten,
schauen, wo was ist.
Das habe ich immer so gemacht.
Mein Charakter veränderte
sich nicht, blieb immer gleich.
Ich war immer dieselbe Person,
nur das Erscheinungsbild ist anders.
Das Erscheinungsbild
hat sich dem Charakter angepasst.
Nicht umgekehrt.
* Funkspruch *
Mich stimmt positiv,
was ich in der Armee erlebt habe.
In unserer Gesellschaft,
v.a. bei den Jüngeren,
ist es nicht mehr so ...
Sie haben teils weniger Vorurteile
als die ältere Generation.
Es wird selbstverständlich,
und das ist dringend an der Zeit.
* Dynamische Klaviermusik *
(Funkspruch) Angriff weiterführen
bis Eintritt ...
Christine habe sich den
Oberleutnant-Rang nicht abverdient,
weil sie ein Mann gewesen sei,
sondern weil sie es konnte.
Dass sie heute hier stehe,
sei keine milde Gabe,
sie habe es sich verdient,
ist sie überzeugt.
Manchmal, so scheint es, ist es
wohl besser, Staub aufzuwirbeln,
als aus Angst
bewegungslos Staub anzusetzen.
Mami, weisst du, was ich mache?
Nein.
- Einen Heli-Platz.
Was? Fast kein Wasser mehr.
Da müssen wir uns beeilen,
Sand reintun.
Jetzt.
So.
Film doch mich.
Das ist viel interessanter.
* Kleinkindlaute *
Das wird viel besser.
Weniger dumm.
Christines Eltern
haben ihren beiden Kindern
stets die gewünschte
Liebe und Geborgenheit geschenkt.
Das hat sich auch nach
Christines Outing nicht geändert.
Die Eltern leben heute getrennt,
haben aber zu Christine ein gutes,
vielleicht sogar
ehrlicheres Verhältnis.
Hallo.
- Hallo.
Du hast mir wieder
etwas eingebrockt.
* Sie lachen. *
Julia ist nicht dabei?
Nein, sie ist noch bei Laura.
Die beiden verbringen schon
die ganze Woche zusammen.
Okay.
Das war zwar so nicht geplant,
aber sie war am Sonntag bei uns.
Eine Nacht lang war sie bei uns,
und die zweite Nacht
verbringt sie bei Laura.- Okay.
* Vogelzwitschern *
Ich habe hier ...
- Das ist dein Album.
Ja, also ...
- Das war das erste Mal in Ägypten.
Das war bei der Moschee,
als ich die Schuhe ausziehen musste.
Stimmt, das ist wahr.
- Das fand ich gar nicht lustig.
Das ist in Gizeh.
- Ja, genau.
Hoppla.
Frau Hug, wenn Sie gefragt werden,
ob Sie Kinder haben,
was antworten Sie?
- Ja.
Ein Sohn und eine Tochter.
Das ist klar. Ab und zu
verwechsle ich noch den Namen.
Denn wenn man 70 Jahre lang
Christian sagt ...
Nicht ganz 70.
Doch.
- Nur 40.
Stimmt, natürlich.
40 Jahre lang
habe ich Christian gesagt.
Dann ist es plötzlich nicht
mehr Christian, sondern Christine.
Deshalb habe ich für mich ...
Früher, als du klein warst,
warst du Chriseli.
Lange Zeit
warst du ein Dreikäsehoch.
Dann dachte ich für mich:
Chrigi, das klingt schön.
Das klingt für mich passend.
Ja.
Da waren wir in Arenzano.
- Genau.
Damals wickelte ich dich
noch auf der Motorhaube.
* Sie lachen. *
Tempi passati.
Ja, lange her.
Ich fragte mich,
weshalb ich das nie bemerkt hatte.
Dann sagte mir Chrigi klar:
"Mami, das hättest du
gar nicht merken können."
Sie kaschierte das so gut.
Und es war
nur phasenweise offensichtlich.
Zwischendurch
war es wieder ganz normal.
Aber obwohl ich es nicht
bemerkt hatte,
musste Chrigi diese Phasen
ja so empfunden haben.
Oder? Stimmt das so?
- Ja.
Es war so ...
Es kam meistens dann,
wenn ich Zeit hatte,
über mich selber nachzudenken.
Wenn ich beschäftigt war,
was meistens der Fall war,
dachte ich weniger daran,
stand es weniger im Vordergrund.
Es war meistens während Zeiträumen,
in denen ich Zeit hatte,
mich zu reflektieren.
Die Gedanken kamen meistens,
als ich für mich alleine war.
Es kommt noch etwas dazu:
Ähm ...
Mein Eindruck war immer ...
Du wolltest immer ...
... in erster Linie
dem Vater nacheifern.
Etwa im Bereich des Militärs.
Und ganz allgemein hatte ich
bei den Interessen immer das Gefühl,
dass da ...
... ein kleiner Papi nachkommt.
Das war sehr ausgeprägt.
Kann ich jetzt schiessen?
- Ja.
* Nachgeahmtes Schussgeräusch *
Ein klassisches
männliches Rollenbild bedeutet,
stark und selbstbewusst aufzutreten.
Auch, was die Interessen betrifft:
Man ist stark, treibt Sport,
dient im Militär.
Man hat Führungsverantwortung,
sagt, wo es langgeht.
Das sind überlieferte,
gewachsene Rollenbilder.
Sie haben aber mit der Realität
gar nichts zu tun.
Trotzdem werden sie durch
unsere Gesellschaft aufoktroyiert.
Entsprechend versucht man, diesen
Bildern unterbewusst zu entsprechen.
Ohne dass es einem
bewusst so gesagt wird.
Das beginnt mit kleinen Dingen.
Z.B. wie man sich kleidet,
wie man sich teils zu geben hat,
für was man sich
zu interessieren hat - oder nicht.
Das ist eigentlich
völliger Blödsinn.
Das ist etwas,
das permanent
hinterfragt werden muss.
Was sind diese Rollenbilder
überhaupt? Woher kommen sie?
Und was bezwecken sie?
Wieso sind sie, wie sie sind?
Und müssen sie so sein?
Es ist nur die Hülle,
die anders ist.
Aber was die Person betrifft,
ist das hier
nach wie vor meine Chrigi.
Es ist genau derselbe Mensch.
Sie hat einfach
offensichtlich das Bedürfnis,
eine Frau
und kein Mann mehr zu sein.
Verschiedenste Menschen waren,
als ich sagte,
dass ich jetzt Christine sei,
mehr als überrascht.
Sie waren nicht gerade verstört,
aber ich merkte,
dass sie nicht wussten,
wie sie das einordnen sollen.
Ich denke:
Das Wichtigste,
um akzeptiert zu werden, ist,
auch da sich selber zu sein.
Und man sollte eigene Probleme
nicht auf andere projizieren,
denn die verschwinden so nicht.
Man sollte sich selber
und offen sein
und zu sich selber stehen können -
und das anderen gegenüber
natürlich rüberbringen können.
* Wiehern *
Christine sagt,
sie habe seit ihrem Outing
vor vier Jahren
keine schlechten Reaktionen erlebt.
Für Ehefrau Tanja
ist die Situation eine andere.
Sie lebt heute nicht das Leben,
das sie sich immer gewünscht hat.
Von aussen als lesbisches Paar
gelesen zu werden,
bereitet ihr immer noch Mühe.
Ich wusste, dass das Christine ist,
und dachte, dass sei die Mutter.
Mehr wusste ich nicht.
Dann kamen sie beide und ich dachte,
das könne irgendetwas sein.
Die Freundin, die Kollegin -
oder sie sind ein lesbisches Paar.
Das spielt gar keine Rolle.
Aber im Gespräch merkte ich,
dass das eher nach der Mutter klang.
Das war etwas seltsam,
im Sinne von:
Jetzt wird es spannend.
Ich hatte keine Ahnung,
und es ging mich auch nichts an.
Aber es war spannend.
Und dann sagte es mir Tanja.
Dann brauchte es noch einen Moment,
es war etwas ungewohnt.
Aber dieses Erklären
machte es damals viel einfacher,
denn danach war es klar.
Wir waren eigentlich
ein ganz normales Ehepaar,
jetzt ist es halt etwas speziell.
Was auch immer normal bedeuten soll.
- Ja.
Aber es ist jetzt einfach so.
Aber ich habe jeweils das Bedürfnis,
ganz klar zu sagen,
was die Situation ist.
Und ich habe
in der Vergangenheit gespürt,
dass so das Eis gebrochen wird.
Und so gibt es keine Fragezeichen,
die im Kopf umherschwirren.
Das erste Mal,
als wir diese Situation hatten -
das war nicht hier -
war es mir zunächst unangenehm.
Ich fand es unnötig,
das zu erklären.
Mittlerweile habe ich erfahren,
dass es durchaus wichtig ist.
Man trifft auf Personen,
die dich und die Hintergründe
nicht kennen.
Es gibt halt Dinge,
die als normal betrachtet werden.
Und die Personen
ziehen Rückschlüsse
aufgrund der Lebensweise
und der gesellschaftlichen Normen.
Und wenn es anders ist,
dann ist es keine Blossstellung,
sondern es hilft dem Verständnis.
Es ist nicht wertend gemeint,
sondern hilft dem Verständnis.
Andere Menschen
verstehen es so besser.
In meinen kühnsten Träumen
hätte ich mir
meine heutige Lebenssituation
nicht so vorstellen können,
wie sie nun ist.
Vor 20 Jahren wäre das für mich
absolut unvorstellbar gewesen.
Ja.
Ich hatte mich ...
... in einen Mann verliebt -
und nicht in eine Frau.
Es ist jetzt so:
Wir sind eine Frauen-WG.
Chrige,
unsere Tochter Julia und ich.
Und ...
Nana, ober eben Christine,
ist immer noch mein Lieblingsmensch.
Und ...
Es ist ein spannender Prozess,
denn ich befinde mich noch selber
in diesem Prozess.
Man kann es sich so vorstellen:
Es ist nicht so,
dass ich verwitwet bin.
Ich habe meinen Mann nicht
durch den endgültigen Tod verloren.
Mein "Mann" ist immer noch da,
aber er ist im Körper einer Frau.
Es ist, wie es ist.
Ich bin seit vielen Jahren
mit Tanja zusammen.
Wir kennen uns ...
... auf unsere Art.
Das Sexuelle
hat heute weniger Bedeutung,
als das früher der Fall war.
Würde ich mich
als lesbisch bezeichnen?
Vielleicht.
Ich kann es nicht genau sagen.
Ich hinterfrage es nicht.
Ich bin in dieser Beziehung.
Es spielt für mich keine Rolle.
Hoffentlich passt der.
Dieser?
Ja, das sollte gehen.
Nichts gegen meine Mama,
aber sie hat ziemliche Angst,
hatte schon einige Unfälle.
Es wird ihr schnell zu viel.
Und ...
Mit Nana sind wir schon
den Fahrradweg, der so steil ist,
hinaufgeritten. Das war ohne Mama.
Wir gehen querfeldein,
durch den Wald.
Auf Trampel- oder Fahrradpfaden.
Mama ist für solche Sachen
weniger zu haben.
Willst du?
- Mach nur.
Das hängt wahrscheinlich
damit zusammen,
wie ich so bin.
Denn ...
Ich hinterfrage es nicht gross,
man soll im Moment leben.
Dazu gehört, zwischendurch
ein wenig herumzualbern.
Gell, Julia?
- Ja.
Das gehört dazu,
um das Leben zu geniessen.
Ja.
Ich halte das Motorrad.
- Am besten etwas nach oben heben.
Das Ding ist schwer.
- Soll ich ihn anheben?
Dann kannst du das Rad ausfädeln.
- Nein, danke.
Aua.
- Achtung.
Danke.
- Jetzt kannst du das Rad nehmen.
Hopp.
Jetzt unten rausziehen.
- Ja.
Ich kann nicht mehr tun,
als es versuchen.
Am besten nach hinten rausrollen.
Genau.
Geschafft.
- Gut.
Uff.
- Nun kannst du es rausnehmen.
Tipptopp.
- Und weiter?
Stell ihn an den Pfosten.
- Ans Lanzenziel.
Die Reaktion von Julia war ...
... sehr erwachsen.
Viel erwachsener
als von vielen Erwachsenen.
Das sah ich
auch bei anderen Kindern.
Sie sind
deutlich weniger vorbelastet
durch irgendwelche Haltungen,
wie es vermeintlich zu sein habe.
Sondern: Sie nehmen die Situation,
wie sie ist,
sie nehmen die Menschen,
wie sie sind ist, urteilen nicht.
Sie nehmen es einfach so auf.
Das merkte ich bei Julia sehr stark
und schätzte sehr,
wie sie damit umging.
Sie fragte völlig gelassen:
"Was soll das ändern?
Du bist ja weiterhin du."
Und von dieser Grösse,
die Kinder an den Tag legen -
davon könnten sich viele Erwachsene
eine grosse Scheibe abschneiden.
Das Ding ist schwer.
Die alte Klasse
hat es relativ schnell begriffen.
Es wurde immer wieder
nach meinem Papi gefragt.
Dann sage ich immer:
meine Nana.
Dann fragen sie: wer?
Sie sprechen von Papi, ich von Nana.
Und wenn neue Kinder dazu-
oder in die Klasse kommen,
dann ist das immer  d i e  Frage -
bis sie es begreifen.
Das ist das einzige,
das sich geändert hat.
* Julia singt. *
Ich sage einfach,
dass sie eine Transgender ist.
Bei uns an der Kanti
sollten es die meisten begreifen,
denn sie haben es ja
an die Kanti geschafft.
Kannst du den Werkzeugkoffer ...
- Yes.
So nicht.
- Wie dann?
Julia, so nicht.
Alles hinstellen.
Wie dann?
Das ist die Seite,
auf der alles festgemacht ist.
Die legst du so drauf
und dann schliessen.
Genau.
Eine weiter oben.
* Beschwingte Musik *
Hüa, hüa, hüa!
Jetzt sehen die Bäume wieder
wie Scherenschnitte aus.
Ja.
Also, schälen muss ich sie ja nicht.
* Melancholische Musik *
Wir haben keine Gabeln mitgenommen.
- Wir haben doch Stöcke.
Ja, so kann Julia die Cervelat
am Stock braten. Das ist ideal.
Ich wünsche mir,
dass wir unser spannendes Leben
weiterhin gemeinsam begehen können.
Ich freue mich auch auf
alle kommenden Herausforderungen.
Wir werden zu wenig alt,
um all das umzusetzen,
was wir gerne umsetzen würden.
Es gibt noch viele Sachen -
und dann ist es geschlechterneutral.
Ich versuchte
meiner Familie zu erklären,
dass ich
einen Lieblingsmenschen habe.
Es ist nicht mein Mann,
es ist auch nicht meine Frau.
Beides geht irgendwie nicht.
So habe ich halt einfach
einen Lieblingsmenschen.
Und ohne Lieblingsmensch ...
Auch wenn es an manchen Tagen
sehr schwierig ist
und ich mir selber im Weg stehe
mit meinen Wertevorstellungen.
Trotz allem
ist es immer noch das Schönste,
am Abend zusammen im Bett zu liegen
und zu wissen, dass sie da ist.
Die Entscheidung,
die ich getroffen habe,
war für mich
die absolut richtige Entscheidung.
Es fühlte sich fast so an,
als ob ich das Leben
noch einmal beginnen konnte -
in gewissen Bereichen.
Es ist wie ein neues Leben im Leben.
Was die Zukunft bringt,
weiss niemand so genau.
Es scheint, dass Christine, Tanja
und Julia eine Liebe verbindet,
die jeden Sturm zu bewältigen vermag.
Auch wenn sich die Hülle wandle
und die Welt sich verändere,
die Seele sei doch stets die gleiche.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
Florian Schuler - 2022